breaking news out of Paris and what
looks to be a city under terror attack
on several fronts more than 100 innocent
victims were killed this is a
heartbreaking situation and obviously
those of us here in the United States
know what it's like we've gone through
these kinds of episodes ourselves we've
always been able to count on the French
people to stand with us and we intend to
be there with them
iron front Susan Toyota when heroes for
eylem - our via keye directional finder
51 seenin zona via vine and Medina
my message to the French people is
simple new song Solidaire avec vous new
song too small for me we stand with you
United
Tobi's no céntimos golpeado por los
brutally setenta dos de Parys los
españoles sabemos lo que es evil or
illumos you freedo incarnate probiem
when the French people left the stadium
after that shocking attack they were not
card they sang their national anthem
proudly and that is how all three people
should respond to these assaults freedom
stands up for itself stands up for its
values in the face of terrorism satanic
toda gear yet eco me Tahoe - Mentalist -
Nami jihadist conference contra de
valor' coup de foto back to Don Ramon
Kosuke Newsom happy Leoben kabbalah
allow some bloggers a planet